[Music]
okay everyone i'm really really excited
today because i have the privilege of
talking to
janelle parrish aka margot from the to
all the boys series and it's really
exciting because coming out soon in
netflix is the third and final
installment
to all the boys always and forever
janelle how are you doing today
i'm good how are you i'm doing really
good um
so what's i just watched the film
last night i loved it and what's really
interesting about the third film is it
really kind of
lays into the relationship and how
important your character of margot is
to lara jean so knowing in real life
that you have an older sister do you
take from that relationship she's like
how she talks to you to how you portray
margot to lara jean
yeah absolutely i mean my sister is my
margot
in every way i remember when she left to
go to college
i cried and was mad at her that she was
abandoning me
very similar to lara jane when she finds
out that
margot is going off to college in
scotland um and she i rely on her for
everything she's my best friend my
confidant
um so i had never been a big sister
before i never even played a big sister
so um when getting ready for margot i
definitely drew from
my own big sister and what a sounding
board she was for me
that yeah that's awesome and that's
great that you could take from your
personal life to bring to this role and
it really shows well
and i love about your character too is
in the first film
where you know margo just drops josh
when she gets to a school
in scotland can you kind of compare
margot
to our main character lara jean where
that main difference is
but how valuable that kind of is yeah i
think with margo like she knows
exactly what she wants uh she sees
so clearly what her path is and all the
steps that she needs to take to get
there she's very methodical
this is my plan and this is what i need
to do in order to do it
and i'm so focused and that's what it is
and lara jean
who i'm more like i'm not like margot at
all uh
is more just like but my feelings and
i'm pulled in this direction and what
about this direction and
you know fantasies and fantasizing what
could be
and and margot was like okay that's
great
but come back to the real world and
let's think things out and be methodical
um and so it's kind of funny because in
real life i'm the lara jean and my
sister is the margot who's like
oh cape of focus like what what do we
got to do
in this situation right
no that that's really funny actually and
uh also speaking of funny kind of
switching gears a bit but i think you're
one of the funniest social media
presence and that's on twitter
and instagram what i love about your
insta story
is that you were posting like behind the
scenes yesterday of your press
tour and i actually thought it was
really cool to see because you got like
the books like we all do on the computer
you even put on one of your pictures you
got the christmas pjs on
i got my blanket today i love that so
is that like is that if there's one
thing that's like you know you could
take as a positive from how like the
world's kind of operating now like are
you going to kind of miss this about
press tours now like
in the times where you could just be in
your pajamas where you couldn't do that
in the past
you know what this is actually making me
appreciate more
going out and doing press i always was
sort of somebody who would get really
nervous
and you know getting in the car going to
a new place i was like oh i'm feeling a
little anxious and getting the
butterflies like
i'd always just be worried that the day
wouldn't go well and then by the time
the day was over i'd be like what a
great day i wish i didn't worry so much
because it was so wonderful
and now doing it from home as lovely as
it is to sit here with my
you know pj bottoms and my blanket i'm
like
wow i really appreciate and miss
the days where we would get to travel
for press and be in the same room with
our co-stars and
be in the same room with you guys and
have that one-on-one experience so
perspective it's definitely made me i
think i i won't get as anxious or
nervous anymore because i miss it
it's really special to have that you
know
yeah that that's really interesting and
it's interesting too because that answer
you just gave is very genuine and real
and i think that
you also on your presence in social
media is very genuine and real
and i actually love that because you had
a tweet on january 19th that was
i def just danced around my kitchen to
one day more now
les miz is one of my fav is my favorite
play
by miles and i know you played young
cozette yeah i have to ask this question
but
if you were to play in les mis today who
would you want to play
now that you're older now that i'm older
ah man
i don't know because my voice falls
right in between eponine
and little cossette but i feel like my
soul
wants to play eponine because i just
love how
angsty her role is and how powerful her
songs are so
or maybe fontine no but epinephrine
has more songs i'm gonna go with eponine
love it
and uh that's a great pick and i think
you would totally kill it so i hope one
day it happens
um so wrapping things up going back to
the film knowing this is the final
film in this series was it really
emotional on set
is there something also that you would
take away from this experience that
you'd bring to the rest of your
career yeah man we just feel so
grateful i mean when we filmed the first
movie we we knew there were three books
but there's no guarantee that the
movie's gonna take off enough for you to
be able to do
two let alone all three movies so to
finally be here
um debuting our third movie is so
bittersweet we're so proud we can't wait
for the fans to see it
it's truly a beautiful ending to lara
jean's story
as well as a beginning to the next
chapter for life but yeah that last day
um we were lucky we all got to wrap
together the three sisters
in korea and uh there were lots of tears
it's just a beautiful
you know beautiful journey that's coming
to an end but
yeah yeah i mean and i'm gonna miss it
i'm gonna miss especially i love the
scenes with the three sisters together
and i think
it really is at the core the most
important part of this story and it's
represented really well in
this series and uh i have to ask one
more question before i
lose you is that because you're in
quarantine like all of us is there
anything recently on netflix that you
could suggest that you actually enjoyed
watching or
have jumped into i binge the hell
out of bridgerton i'm one of them yeah
like i was like all right let's see what
this fuss is all about
i watched all episodes in two days
i did not like my how i was obsessed
it's so fun
oh that's awesome to hear that's that's
just see everyone if you haven't watched
bridgerton that's your
your best suggestion you can get from
janelle parish herself
yep and after that you should obviously
binge to all the boys
uh series yep and always in forever's
coming out
february 12th on netflix the final
chapter in this story
uh you get to see janelle as margot
janelle i cannot wait to watch it
and uh thank you so much for joining me
today thank you
have a good one